de chico siempre círculo inquieta si no
estaba vendiendo limones de mi patio o
dulces que hacía mi abuelo estaba
haciendo algún deporte o armando y
desarmando algo era un fanático de los
legos estos ladrillos que no van
castrando para armar casas autos
edificios me la pasaba horas y horas
tirada en la alfombra de mi habitación
buscando piezas ingeniando mira para
construir lo que quería con lo que tenía
el primer stop que la vida me impone es
a los 12 años cuando me diagnosticando
un tumor cerebral maligno que requirió
en operación y tratamiento de
radioterapia posterior
de pronto había pasado estar jugando un
partido de fútbol con mis amigos a estar
pelado con 33 puntos en la cabeza con
sobrepeso por los corticoides y un brazo
sin poder de mover
este suceso me sirvió mucho aprendizaje
logré entender que el único breve en
esta tierra somos nosotros
levy es efímera frágil fugaz e
impredecible
pasó algún tiempo y estaba en tercer año
de la carrera industrial cuando los
conceptos como reciclado sustentabilidad
medioambiente y conciencia ambiental
cada vez eran más frecuentes
investigando también descubrí que la
problemática de la contaminación
ambiental y el calentamiento global eran
mucho más grave de lo que yo pensaba
al tiempo que un proyecto open source
llamados precios plástico unos chicos de
bandas habían subido gratuitamente
internet vídeos tutoriales y planos para
replicar maquinaria de bajo costo para
reciclar plástico
la primera es una trituradora que sirve
para romper el plástico en pedacitos más
pequeños gracias a sus cuchillas
dispuestas helicoidalmente encanta es el
valor la segunda es una extrusora donde
el plástico se vierte por encima en la
tolva y una especie de tornillo lo
empujando a medida que se derrite
gracias a las resistencias que abras en
el caño de la punta sale un fideo de
plástico muy caliente que puede
utilizarse para hacer filamento de
impresión 3d por ejemplo
la tercera es una inyectora muy parecida
el anteayer predispuesta verticalmente y
la fuerza para empujar el plástico se
ejerció manualmente mediante un brazo
palanca así productos de menor volumen
pero mayor grado de precisión
la última es una compresora
tiene un horno con un piso que sea
levemente un gato que logra que me haya
que el plástico se va derritiendo
también se va comprimiendo en el molde
que se le ponga logra hacer productos de
mayor volumen como macetas o placas
al ver esto lo primero que se viene a la
mente es no puede ser tan difícil vamos
a probar
al segundo día ya estaba de hablar con
proveedores y pidiendo presupuestos
descubriendo también que aquellos con
humildes ahorros que había logrado
juntar trabajando en un kiosco durante
el verano pronto se van a portar más
rápido de lo que yo pensaba
resultó que hacer la trituradora que
había visto en un vídeo de 15 minutos
que requería una inversión x terminó
dejándome tres meses y diez veces más
dinero del programa pero en ese lapso
aprendí a soldar y manejar máquinas y
herramientas metalmecánicas logré que
vincularan también el proyecto en la
incubadora de vivero metalúrgico un
incubadora es un espacio dentro de un
ente público privado que se dedica a
orientar direccionar y convertir una
idea en un modelo de negocios y de ahí
ayudar a conseguir inversión
la cosa fue avanzando y junto a luciano
pasamos de fabricación y venta de
máquinas capacitaciones en universidades
y colegios fábricas y una baja escala de
productos a pedidos o propios como
nuestro primer caballito de batalla es
hecho en un molde de bajo costo
revestimiento decorativo de pared
monedas de intercambios y otros
productos
fortaleciendo también la logística del
recuperado y hasta tuvimos el agrado de
recibir la visita de matías uno de los
creadores del proyecto mundial precios
plásticos
lejos de inquietarme que todo el tiempo
estábamos reinventándonos y haciendo
cosas distintas
estaba tranquilo de que teníamos bien en
claro el propósito de por qué lo
hacíamos y lo seguimos haciendo para
ayudar con vivir en un espacio más
sostenible somos un proyecto de triple
impacto que no solamente busca un rédito
económico sino también un beneficio para
la sociedad y el medio ambiente
principalmente
ofrecemos sustentabilidad mediante el
servicio de fabricación de productos de
plástico reciclado a empresas o
emprendimientos que quieran sumar un
valor ambiente a las organizaciones nos
llegan residuos plásticos de distintos
puntos de recolección hacemos una
exhaustiva clasificación de tipo calidad
y color limpieza y procesamiento para
luego ser utilizados como materia prima
en el proceso de inyección de plástico
así luce una máquina inyector de última
generación
hace dos años obtuvimos nuestra primer
máquina inyectores
aproximadamente del año 1009 70
está más para el museo que para otra
cosa
nuestro primer trabajo a escala que
llegó para hacer un reloj
cuando el cliente y federico me pregunta
y aquí están seguros de ustedes que
pueden fabricar este producto en
plástico reciclado
obviamente que respondí sí por supuesto
tenemos todo lo que hace falta lo vamos
a hacer
pero por dentro tengo que admitir que
fue como si me hubiesen dicho que no se
tenemos que fabricar una pieza del apolo
13 mínimas tolerancias entre componentes
y en castres muy complejos
parece entonces de esta máquina sabía un
poco y nada apenas habíamos hecho
algunas pruebas pero nos arremangamos y
en plena pandemia comenzamos a aprender
variables del proceso sumamente
complejas
este fue el resultado
relojes de pulsera de plástico 100
reciclado que se exportan a europa
en las incubadoras se suelen decir que
cuando evalúan un proyecto el 50 por
ciento del puntaje que está en el equipo
emprendedor
sólo no es lo hablado nunca nada
no me alcanzaría el tiempo de la charla
para agradecer y nombrar a todas las
personas que lo hicieron posible
creo que ninguno del equipo sabía las
consecuencias de todo lo que veníamos
haciendo era un crecimiento lineal sino
todos los contrarios estábamos avanzando
y de forma exponencial nunca me hubiese
imaginado la posibilidad de trabajar con
grandes empresas ofreciendo
sustentabilidad y responsabilidad social
empresarial fortaleciendo el equipo de
una perspectiva más interdisciplinaria
mejorando la infraestructura productiva
haciendo acuerdos con actores del
sistema para generar sinergias y
llamando la atención de antes
gubernamentales
acá un paréntesis para comentarles de
dónde sale uno de mis mayores fuentes de
inspiración
mi tatarabuelo abdón sabe si yo no tenía
más que el segundo grado
fue un gran autodidacta
sobre más conocía fue la casa giratoria
registra y patenta como la primera en
todo el mundo en argentina brasil
francia e inglaterra
fabricada que en córdoba en tan solo
cuatro años e inaugurada en mil 951
si hace 70 años
mi abuelo me suele contar como su abuelo
con los materiales y tecnologías que
dispone en la época pudo lograr su sueño
ante cualquier pronóstico
una vez me dijo algo que me quedó
grabado
la consecuencia de cualquier decisión
dependerá de la firmeza de la
determinación
tenéis que animarte ser positivo
extrovertido buscar la forma de
concretar lo encontrará ayuda porque
solo te será muy difícil emprender ser
maduros y no enamorarte de una sola idea
ya la vez estar abierto a críticas
constructivas y sobre todo nunca pierdas
las ganas si vos no crees en tu idea
nadie más lo va a hacer conocerás a
personas maravillosas y tendrás
experiencias inolvidables y en mi
opinión no hay nada más placentero que
ver funcionar a algo que creaste desde
cero junto a tu equipo con esto tampoco
quiero decirte que no habrá desaciertos
pero justamente de eso se trata de
equivocarse y lo más rápido posible
aprendiendo y mejorando constantemente
no tiene sentido obsesionarse con el
resultado sin detenerte y disfrutar del
proceso y las personas que te rodean
en este aspecto y me considero un
experto así que el camino recinto
también se queda mucho por aprender pero
de algo sí estoy seguro soy emprendedor
y me animé de si pasó de tener una idea
a ser proactivo y llevarla adelante las
limitaciones más grandes que descubrí a
la hora de hacer esto fueron las que yo
mismo me impuse a veces tenemos que
decir que sí a cosas que no sabemos si
van a funcionar
de ese niño envuelto en tanta fragilidad
de si nietos inspirado por su abuelo
y este hombre guiado por la pasión
esperamos haberte motivado aunque sea un
poco a que salgas a la luz y entre en
acción ser emprendedor no es sólo una
forma de trabajar es una actitud hacia
la vida
muchas gracias